[Applause]
in just a few weeks a growing social
concern has turned into a major
political issue on Thursday hundreds of
vehicles made their way along major
roads from northern Israel to deliver a
message to leaders in Jerusalem
Palestinian Israelis fed up of the
violence plaguing their communities are
calling for change Israel's most senior
Arab politician using regular Facebook
updates from the route to make clear
their demands the organized crime gangs
the extortion gangs the black market
gangs the weapons these four things if
the police want they can eliminate them
entirely within one or two months once
in West Jerusalem all day and other
members of the Parliament or Knesset
went to meet Israel's public security
minister other protesters gathered
nearby to highlight a surge in crime
that has seen more than 70 people killed
so far this year every few days
Palestinian Israelis wake up to another
story of another fatal crime they say
that police are failing to intervene
failing to investigate essentially they
say their communities have been
abandoned to a sense of insecurity of
violence and of fear fear that came
horrific ly true for Isham on our
earlier this month three of her sons
were involved in a confrontation over
money with another man two of them asked
Medan Khalil was shot and killed the
suspected gunman remains at large there
is no security anymore my son's were
shot at noon the killer didn't consider
the children who were going home from
school such audacity to open fire like
this what kind of world are we living in
we are sitting in our homes and we are
afraid no security where is the law the
government the killings in the northern
town of Maj Dale Crum sparked mass
protests and a pledge from the Public
Security Minister Gallardo Dan to deploy
specialist units and hundreds more
officers recognizing he said the
responsibility of law enforcement to
tackle the crime wave
but many Palestinian Israelis say that
responsibility has been deliberately
shirked over many years we have no trust
in the police we call on the police to
do their job to collect weapons to the
police even have the intention to fight
crime these are questions that are
ten newly elected parliamentarians from
the joint list the Arab majority
political parties in the Knesset took
the rare step of endorsing Benjamin
Netanyahu's main opponent after last
month's general election aiming to get
action on crime and other priorities but
with the stalemate over attempt to form
any new government protesters say
they'll continue to campaign instead on
the streets until their demands are met
Harry Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem